merci
j'hallucine
comment ça va très bien nous arriver du
théâtre là donc ça s'est bien passé
très bien triomphe comme d'habitude
comme d'habitude une coupe et on a très
bien les plaines et tous les genres
appel 8 fois
mine de rien on a un point en commun oui
lesquels on a démarré à faire de la télé
à peu près ensemble moi même une écurie
sera nommé curé je te rassure vous avez
un point commun c'est que steevy et mono
sexuelle et et vous aussi la pitance
alors s'ils vivent très très chargé avec
on a tout essayé ça se passe plutôt bien
ça va oui je fais mes premiers pas sur
la télévision publique
et alors et alors ça se passe plutôt
bien on se fait quelques petites erreurs
parce que c'est toi c'est que fasse
gaffe pu apprendre métier je peux pas
arriver comme ça l'âge de 22 ans et être
un pro comme ça des médias j'apprends
fur et à mesure bien sûr et quoi comme
erreur quoi comme gap
je me trompe dans les expressions alors
que c'est quelque chose que je ne fais
jamais j'ai du mal à parler dexu à la
télé alors que dans la vie je m'exprime
très bien c'est pas être le cas dans la
vie c'est qu'on s'en rend pas compte en
fait ah oui ça fait dix ans le théâtre
m
et oui c'est ça tous les soirs donc si
vite l affiche de la presse est unanime
au théâtre des variétés et pièce de
laurent ruquier avec isabelle mergault
isabelle alonso claude sarraute
gérard muller rappelle nice rails quel
chemin parcouru quand même d'en bas
depuis la sortie du loft et oui ça fait
beaucoup
c'est beaucoup de travail je travaille
voilà ouais stevie dans la pièce vous
faites le rôle d'un attaché de presse
oui alors ce soir je vais vous demander
d'être l'attaché de presse de la pièce
et wendel à yves bot tier 1
voilà wendel a - non c'est une pièce
génial c'est sam été vu il c'est un
vaudeville c'est une pièce de boulevard
c'est bien mélanger puis laurent ruquier
mais il a un talent d'écriture énormes
en fin de compte la thèse raconte
l'histoire du comédien qui sera un film
et son mari est critique pour le figaro
et son mari va critiquer va faire un
article à 500 sur la sur le film de sa
femme donc forcément ça va créer un big
bang au tour de tous les personnages et
c'est génial non mais c'est génial peut
vraiment aller voir je pense que si vous
voulez être producteur nous en sortir
est plutôt gagnants